[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
the so-called doomsday called duo
prosecutors announced they will seek the
death penalty for lori valente bell but
first this is the most painful and
difficult thing i've ever gone through
amber heard takes the stand in the
contentious defamation lawsuit plus i
knew it was
wrong and i knew that i had to leave him
and that's what broke my heart
what she says caused johnny depp to
become abusive and later a forensic
psychologist describes depp's alleged
abuse when mr jeff was drunk or high he
threw her on the bed ripped off her
nightgown and tried to have sex with her
we are live in fairfax virginia with day
14 of testimony long crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Applause]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer we're
hearing from amber heard for the first
time on the stand as a defendant in the
multi-million dollar defamation suit
takes a stand
our own jesse weber is live at the
fairfax county courthouse in virginia
where heard's testimony began thursday
afternoon jesse
yeah brian this is the testimony that
we've been waiting for amber heard
telling her story in her own words but
you know before we even get to her the
day started off with the
cross-examination of herd's first
witness forensic psychologist dr don
hughes and you recall that dr hughes
testified that heard showed symptoms and
signs of being a victim of domestic
violence but depp's attorney tried to
show that the doctor was biased towards
only thinking of men as perpetrators of
violence they had her acknowledge that
it was possible her attack depth and she
also confirmed that everything heard
told this doctor was already after she
had been sued by depp which kind of
makes herd's account a bit curious but
then it was the moment when amber heard
the defendant in this case and also the
plaintiff in her counter suit took the
stand and she explained that being sued
and sitting in court these past few
weeks is the most difficult painful
thing that she has ever gone through and
she started by recounting her upbringing
her move to hollywood and how she met
and fell in love with johnny depp after
meeting him on the set of the rum diary
but soon the testimony took a grim turn
as she described the first time depp
allegedly hit her
slapped me across the face
and i laughed
i laugh
because i
i didn't know what else
to do i thought
this must be a joke
this must be a joke
because i'm
i didn't know what was going on
i just stared at him
kind of laughing still
thinking
that he was going to start laughing too
to tell me it was a joke but he didn't i
didn't want to leave him i didn't want
this to be the reality i didn't want to
have the man i was in love with
i know you don't come back from that you
know not dumb i
i know you can't hit
a woman i you can't hit a man you can't
hit anyone you can't just
hit somebody because they
i knew there was no i knew it was
wrong and i knew that i had to leave him
and that's what broke my heart
because i didn't want to leave him
i thought if i got up out of that room
and i would leave the best thing that
ever happened to me
now we think that herd will be on the
stand for quite some time and of course
things will get very interesting when
she faces cross-examination by depp's
counsel brian
now jesse i'm here in new york
anticipating waiting for her to take the
stand but you're there in virginia what
was the jury's reaction and everyone
else's reaction when herd finally took
the stand
well both the jury and everyone in that
gallery were glued to amber heard they
didn't look down very much i will tell
you the jury was taking a lot of notes
and from what i could see one of the
female jurors actually was nodding your
head just a little bit when amber heard
was discussing the upbringing with
horses and that so there seemed to be
maybe in a bit of an acknowledgment
there but i will tell you that what i've
been hearing in the courtroom just the
whispers and remember this seems to be a
predominantly johnny depp supported
courtroom are people who are making
comments about her testimony and not
quite agreeing or believing what she has
to say it's a fascinating sight brian
yeah jesse i'm used to cross-examining
people as a defense attorney so one
thing kind of made my ears perk up her
described this first alleged slap by
johnny depp a few things stuck out to me
first that she called it stupid and
insignificant and then that she said
that he slapped her off of the couch but
it didn't hurt
how would you describe her retelling
that story
look it's her story there are people
going to look at and say oh she's
manufacturing this it looks rehearsed
it's not really for me to say it's for
the jury to ultimately say because i
wasn't there and this is her account
it's all going to be whether or not they
believe her and remember it's all about
if they believe at least one alleged
instance of domestic abuse and she might
win this case that's all that it takes
so her recounting this was a really
important moment because it symbolized
the first time that she was physically
attacked by johnny depp yeah now
amazing job this this afternoon during
lunch where you and gene rossi taking
people's questions but one thing i kind
of disagreed with him that we have a
week off next week where no testimony is
happening i could see the lawyers
getting together and saying hey let's
resolve this everyone got their story
out we don't need a decision could we
not see this case continue after this
break after herd's done testifying
it's a it's a great point because this
is not only a case in the court of law
it's also the case of court of public
opinion amber heard fired her pr team
for a reason and it makes me wonder was
johnny depp taking the stand tells his
side of the story she takes the stand
she tells her side of the story they
settle it and then allow the public to
try to make what is best of both of them
that could be a possibility because why
risk it for a jury we'll wait and see
but it's definitely a possibility yeah
no one's got 50 million or 100 million
dollars and they just want their
reputation back i don't know we'll see
how it plays out jesse we're going to
come right back great reporting as
always still ahead on law and crime
daily our coverage continues in the
johnny depp versus amber her definition
truck
we take a closer look at amber heard's
testimony why she says her relationship
to death was kept a secret
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back our coverage continues now
in the defamation trial of amber hearn
and johnny depp amber heard testifies
how her relationship with depp began
once we were back from the press tour
you know we had this
you know whirlwind romance kind of just
in these like beautiful places all over
and
we're falling in love and not able to
really show it because um
he wasn't
that the world didn't know about this
split between
he and his former partner
and of course um
some woman i was like what's that
troubling you know and i i'd ask him
no you know we swore to me that they
hadn't even shared a bed for a year and
that they were but they were protecting
the kids and not publicizing it so or
not making it known to the press and so
we kind of had to be a little bit under
the radar not a little bit we had to be
really under the radar
because as
johnny pointed out that the world would
blame me
um and call me a home wrecker
even though i had nothing to do with it
so we were secretly dating and then
you know it was it was beautiful
it was
i
felt like
this man
knew me and saw me in a way that no one
else had
i felt he understood me i felt he
understood
where i came from i i felt like
i felt that like when i was around
johnny i felt like the most beautiful
person in the whole world
you know made me feel seen made me feel
like a million dollars
and
that kind of feeling where you know he's
just
lavish gifts and lavish expressions of
love and how he had never met a woman
like me
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney maria pereira co-host terry
austin and long crime correspondent
jessie weber marie we are hearing and
seeing pictures of amber heard's
injuries or alleged injuries for the
first time does this corroborate her
claims of being a victim of abuse or is
more still needed
i definitely think more is still needed
listen i empathize with a victim of
intimate partner violence i'm um a dv
counselor so i i don't take that lightly
but for now i think the jury and the
depth i'm sorry i think the defense
in the death case has done such a great
job at demonizing her that i'm looking
at her testimony and it's looking a
little bit rehearsed to me and i'm
saying that the injuries she's
describing are not matching up with what
she looked like i'm also a registered
nurse and she's describing back hands
ringed hands it's just too much damage
but the little redness she's showing in
the pictures it doesn't match i would
need more corroboration if i was on the
jury i would need more to show
that type of injury based on what she's
describing interesting point there and
thank you for bringing your expertise to
the table terry from all that we've
heard so far doesn't amber simply need
to show she was not lying about one act
of abuse to beat depp's defamation claim
exactly and jesse mentioned this before
technically if johnny was abusive once
then that's all we need because the
washington post op-ed article would have
been truthful and then that means there
is no defamation claim but it's more
involved than that in my opinion if the
jury thinks that she is making things up
that she's lying that she's exaggerating
that four out of five incidents say for
instance did not happen
that means they could look at all of it
and say that none of it happened and it
is definitely he said she said and that
possibility could exist that they will
discount everything she says because
they don't believe one or two things
that she says
absolutely no jesse let me start off
with this a cavity search of a partner
of a woman man whatever sounds horrific
disgusting but as i listen to amber
heard's allegations about that alleged
cavity search i start to think didn't
she say that she took mushrooms just
moments or minutes beforehand how are we
taking this story as true if she's
admitting that she's high in a substance
where she may hallucinate or exaggerate
what happened
well she said it didn't have an effect
on her yet and you could say how
convenient it didn't have an effect so
obviously you know it didn't have an
effect and you're able to recount this
the other way of looking at it is well
she could have just excluded that fact
and said i never took drugs and look of
course this is an important allegation
because it not only supports domestic
abuse but more specifically the sexual
violence claim which makes up one of the
defamate or alleged defamatory
statements in that washington post op-ed
the problem for amber heard as we were
just hearing from marie a lot of these
allegations are behind closed doors and
the only evidence you have to support it
is the testimony of amber heard so it
all becomes if the jury believes or not
all right jesse great reporting as
always thank you so much for being our
man on the ground so to speak and we'll
look forward to seeing you soon
coming up on law and crime daily we take
a closer look at the abuse allegations
in the johnny depp versus amber heard
trot a forensic psychologist tested
flies for amber hurst team but how does
she hold up on cross that's ahead on
long crime daily
[Music]
welcome back we're getting a closer look
now at the alleged violent relationship
between johnny depp and ex-wife amber
heard on direct examination of forensic
psychologist testified depp called her
demeaning names and violated her
physically and sexually
when mr jeff was drunk or high he threw
her on the bed ripped off her nightgown
and tried to have sex with her
there were times when he
forced her to give him oral sex when he
was angry these weren't in in loving
moments these were angry moments and
moments of dominance moments of him
trying to get control over her there was
another incident in the bahamas where
when he got angry
he took his fingers and he put him in
her vagina and moved her around
violently in the closet
again an act of sexual violence
and of course
the incident in australia was one of the
most severe instances of sexual violence
that um miss heard had to endure in
which when he was
beating her and choking her and telling
her i'm going to kill you i hate you i
hate you i'm going to kill you when he
grabs a bottle that was on the bar and
penetrated her with that bottle
and miss her reported to me of of
dissociating and going outside of her
body and the only thing she was thinking
is
oh god i hope it's not the broken one
on cross-depth's attorneys push back
about the australia incident and heard
alleged actions during the argument
is it your testimony
that
throwing a can of mineral spirits
at your spouse is characteristic
of reactive violence
if you are running away from your spouse
who is trying to hurt you yes
all right so so you can throw a can of
mineral spirits
what about if you throw a can of red
bull
again it depends on what the incident i
think that you're referring to that was
not necessarily reactive violence that
was in a state of frustration or anger
all right so
so when you throw a can of red bull in a
state of frustration or anger that's not
reactive violence
no
[Music]
what about if you throw a bottle of
vodka because your husband fell off the
wagon
is that reactive violence
are you asking me hypothetically i'm
asking you would that ki would that be a
characteristic of
of reactive violence throw a bottle of
vodka because your husband fell off the
wagon
if it's in the middle of an assault
perhaps
if it's independent of that
no
right
for instance if your husband was just
having a couple of shots at the bar
again you wouldn't need more information
and context make that determination all
right
you don't think that's a reflection
reflective of reactive violence and
you'll agree with me
that when you throw the second bottle
that's not reactive violence
if somebody's throwing multiple bottles
again psychological violence and abuse
is psychologically destabilizing which
destabilizes individuals coping
strategies that is absolutely true
terry a shocking point at least to me
came out during dr hughes direct that if
herd came into a session with black eyes
and bruises from depth that resources
would have been put together to help but
that didn't happen so how do you think
either side will use that fact
you know what brian the fact that no one
provided her with first aid means to me
that she did not need first aid and so
no one rendered it and so far everything
we have heard has come from amber
heard's mouth or from her physicians and
she was the one who told all of the
physicians and the nurses this is what
johnny depp did to me and you have to
think about her own testimony today the
fact that she is saying he choked her he
slapped her he held her down he did all
of this violence and yet she had these
minor injuries she has one picture of a
red cheek if in fact he did all of this
like marie said he would have
you know had to
punch her
very heavily and she would have injuries
showing on her face and her body yeah
now maria i think this is part of the
strategy to put dr hughes on first and
then amber heard do you think that the
doctor uh did enough even after
cross-examination to pave the way for
amber heard's testimony
i think under the circumstances that
doctor did an excellent job and i think
choosing to put her on as a first
witness was excellent strategy she don
news was like a vintage version of depth
expert except she was more qualified
board board-certified poised compelling
believable and she stood a grueling
cross and she did not let depp's lawyers
shake her at all she was a winner with
this because she paved the way to
explain what is domestic violence why do
people stay
and she did the best she could to set
the foundation for her testimony it is
just that they did such a good job again
at making her look like a liar a demon a
sick person that is hard to believe her
testimony with all the drama all the
fake crying i don't see a lot of tears
but i see a lot of
acting up there in in my opinion well
amber heard i i would expect we'll be on
the stand for quite some time so let's
see if she's able to do that as we
continue thank you both when we come
back the couple known as the doomsday
duel will soon face trump now
prosecutors intend to seek the death
penalty for chad and lori davos
[Music]
welcome back idaho prosecutors will see
the death penalty against doomsday cult
duo lori and chad dabo recently filed
court documents show chad dabo was
already facing the death penalty in the
case now attorneys in fremont and
madison counties say they'll seek
capital punishment for laurie vallo de
bell as well the state will go for the
death penalty if lori is convicted of
any of the counts of first degree murder
or conspiracy to commit first degree
murder the pair is charged with killing
two of lori's children tyler ryan and
j.j valo tyler ryan and jj were 16 and 7
years old when they were last seen in
september of 2019. lori and chad never
reported them missing and police say
they didn't cooperate with investigators
before fleeing out of state the couple
were found in hawaii a few months later
then in june 2020 the remains of valo's
children were found on chad's property
lori was initially declared mentally
unfit to stand trial but that changed
last month lori is set to go to trial in
october a hearing is set for may 19th to
discuss delaying that to recombine it
with chad's trial date in january 2023
marie was the death penalty expected for
this case or were you shocked by this by
any chance
i was shocked that something like that
would happen those were her children and
i think the death penalty is appropriate
because this act was heinous these
children were helpless and then there
was multiple victims
she and then they tried to to hide it
if any case deserves the death penalty
it would be this one that makes sense in
infant side of your own children is
definitely a heinous crime terry what if
anything does this change procedurally
or how this is going to work out for
lori valodevo and chad dabo's trial
well we know that the death penalty is
constitutional the supreme court has
said that it is and it doesn't violate
the eighth amendment cruel and unusual
punishment but in idaho like most other
states from a procedural standpoint what
it means now is they're going to have to
show the prosecution will have to show
that there are aggravating factors for
the you know murder and for the
conspiracy to commit murder crime and i
don't think that will be a problem there
are multiple aggravating factors
including the fact that it's involving
children there was the disregard for
human life there's this propensity for
these individuals to be committing
murder and they are a continuing threat
to society so i think it's going to be
easy to get it all right well thank you
very much both for your input today and
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you